yes my name is Leo Fernandes i am the
presidents of the dominican republic and
in terms of what people motivated i
should say that personally I've always
been very interested in knowing how I
can't contribute to make a better world
with and in order to do that I say I pay
close attention to ideas I think there
is a power in ideas and you get that
body socializing them by partnering the
different sectors by listening bye-bye
learning by trying to understand and
when you get this then you become
engaged and through engagement comes
participation active participation so
this is what we try to do keep an open
mind in terms of what goes goes on in
the world how that can impact your
country how can that influence different
sectors in your society then you do not
have a passive personality attitude
instead you become very active you
become involved and then that way I
think you can make a contribution even
though it can be a modest contribution
and a personal level but that takes your
life that keeps you motivated and that
that gives meaning to life instead of
just looking inward in an individual can
actually start we're trying to get a new
floor